welcome everyone to the last gasp of the
Russia collusion conspiracy theory as
Democrats continue to voice this
spectacle on the American people as well
as view mr. Muller the American people
may recall the media first began
spreading this conspiracy theory in the
spring of 2016 when fusion GPS funded by
the DNC and the Hillary Clinton campaign
started developing the steel dossier a
collection of outlandish accusations
that Trump and his associates were
Russian agents fusion GPS steel and
other confederates fed these absurdities
to naive or partisan
you
among other things the FBI used dossier
allegations to obtain a warrant to spy
on the Trump campaign despite
acknowledging Dossi a legate dossier
allegations as being salacious and
unverified former FBI director James
Comey briefed those allegations to
President Obama and president electrum
those briefings conveniently leaked to
the press resulting in the publication
of the dossier and launching thousands
of false press stories based on the word
of a foreign X by one who admitted he
was desperate that Trump lose the
election and who was eventually fired as
a FBI source for leaking to the press
after Comey himself was fired by his own
admission he leaked derogatory
information on President Trump to the
press for the specific purpose and
successfully so of engineering the
appointment of a special counsel who
sits here before us today the FBI
investigation was marred by further
corruption and bizarre abuses top DOJ
official Bruce or whose own wife worked
on fusion gps's anti Trump operation fed
steals information to the FBI even after
the FBI fired Steele the top FBI
investigator and his lover another top
FBI official constantly texted about how
much they hated Trump and wanted to stop
him from being elected and the entire
investigation was open based not on five
eyes intelligence but on a tip from a
foreign politician about a conversation
involving Joseph Mifsud he's a Maltese
diplomat who's widely portrayed as a
Russian agent but seems to have far more
connections with Western governments
including our own FBI and our own State
Department than with Russia raising Li
ignoring all these red flags as well as
the transparent absurdity of the claims
they are making the Democrats have
argued for nearly three years that
evidence of collusion
is hidden just around the corner like
the Loch Ness monster they insist it's
there even if no one can find it
consider this in March 2017 Democrats on
this committee said they had more than
circumstantial evidence of collusion but
they couldn't reveal it yet mr. Muller
was soon appointed and they said he
would find the collusion then when no
collusion was found and mr. Mueller's
indictments the Democrats said we'd find
it in his final report then when there
was no collusion in the report we were
told Attorney General Barr was hiding it
then when it was clear Barr wasn't
hiding anything
we were told it will be revealed through
a hearing with mr. Muller himself and
now that mr. Muller is here they are
claiming that the collusion has actually
been in his report all along hidden in
plain sight and they're right there is
collusion in plain sight collusion
between Russia and the Democratic party
the Democrats colluded with Russian
sources to develop the Steele dossier
and Russian lawyer natalia vasko skaia
colluded with a dossiers key architect
fusion gps head Glenn Simpson the
Democrats have already admitted both in
interviews and through their usual
anonymous statements to reporters the
today's hearing is not about getting
information at all they said they want
to quote bring the molar report to life
and create a television moment through
ploys like having mr. Muller recite
passages from his own report in other
words this hearing is political theater
it's a hell Mary attempt to convince the
American people that collusion is real
and that it's concealed in the report
granted that's a strange argument to
make about a report that is public it's
almost like the Democrats prepared
arguments accusing mr. Barr of hiding
the report and didn't bother to update
their claims once he published the
entire thing among congressional
Democrats the Russia investigation was
never about finding the truth it's
always been a simple media operation by
their own accounts this operation
continues in this room today once again
numerous pressing issues this committee
needs to address are put on hold to
indulge the political fantasies of
people who believed it was their destiny
to serve Hillary Clinton's
administration it's time for the curtain
to close on the Russia hoax the
conspiracy theory is dead at some point
I would argue we're gonna have to get
back to work until then I yield back the
balance of my time